these are the faces of the talib
young boys forced onto the streets to
fight for their lives
and some of them are the direct victims
of a climate crisis they have been sent
by their families
from their homes in rural villages all
over west africa
to learn the quran at religious schools
in the towns and cities but when they
get here
many of them are abused exploited and
forced to beg
and steal to earn money for their
masters
we found around a dozen on a massive
rubbish dump outside the city of saint
louis
in northern senegal
it stinks of burning plastic and rubber
flies buzz around rotting food and the
children compete with birds
scavenging for scraps joseph
hasn't seen his parents for two years
and he says he misses them
he spends his days picking and scraping
through the rubbish
looking for small bits of metal to sell
a kilogram
will earn him around 25 cents
that's about 20p once he's found enough
he will walk for five hours in 40 degree
heat
back into the town these are child
slaves and more and more are being
forced into this grim
life the town please
don't know for me
that legendary
[Music]
these photos show talib boys in chains
to stop them running away this boy
managed to escape
with his feet still shackled together it
is a shocking revelation
about what goes on behind the secretive
doors
of the quranic schools
we hear that there are more talib in the
city's fish market and so we go down to
sea
it's quickly clear we're not welcomed by
everyone
it's late afternoon and the boats are
coming in with their catch
talib surround them in the shallow
waters and help the fishermen unload
yes
explained to me is that the talibs are
the ones
yeah rose go ahead you see yeah you see
that
that dean you look there look at that
little kid with two fish okay
let's go with his hands so the talib
come down here
they help the fishermen unload their
fish but any that drop off they take
and then they'll effectively stealing
from the fishermen and they'll sell them
down the market
that's how they try and take money
fish are slipped into pockets down
trousers
and wedged into boots
as the sun goes down the talib head back
to the market to sell their fish
if they don't make enough money they'll
be beaten
it's almost midnight now on the streets
of saint louis
we're with a small organization that
patrols after dark
looking for the boys sleeping rough some
have fled the abuse
others haven't made enough money today
and are scared to return to their
violent masters
but these streets at night are dangerous
for them too
many are raped or physically abused and
the police
just turn a blind eye to it
if the talibs see us white western faces
they will run and so we have to film
discreetly
a camera is strapped to the chest of our
local producer
and they set off in search of the talib
down the small pitch-black alleyways
we have changed their names to protect
them
they are both under 10 years old too
young
to be sleeping rough but they know no
different
they are reluctant at first scared to
leave
but eventually the charity worker
persuades them to come
they sit in the back of the car
wide-eyed silent
and frightened they haven't eaten
properly for days
and their clothes are filthy
we take them to a refuge in the city
where they can spend the night in safety
and have food and a shower
they tell us about the abuse they've
suffered at the hands of their quranic
masters
[Music]
they're here because their families
cannot feed them climate change
has destroyed the countryside they grew
up in and their parents
have no idea what is happening to them
but if ibrahima and ubar go back home
now
they risk being rejected for bringing
shame on their families
and then they'll be back on the streets
again whichever way they turn
there is no escape alastair bunkel sky
news
saint louis in senegal